JOHN HAGY AND OTHERS TO DISCUSS
THE NEW EMBASSY IN THE COMPLEX
ON THE GROUND.
FIRST, MY OPENING STATEMENT.
WE DO JOIN YOU TONIGHT DURING A
TRULY HISTORIC MOMENT IN
ISRAEL'S HISTORY.
ONE THAT CALLS FOR GREAT
CELEBRATION.
THIS WEEK, NOT ONLY HAS
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP CHOSEN TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE DISASTROUS
OBAMA IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL, WE ARE
HERE ON THE EVE OF THE MOMENTOUS
OPENING OF THE AMERICAN EMBASSY
IN JERUSALEM.
A MOVE THAT RECOGNIZES JERUSALEM
AS THE CAPITAL OF ISRAEL.
I MOVE GREATLY APPRECIATED BY
THE PEOPLE OF ISRAEL AS
EVIDENCED ON STREET CORNERS
EVERYWHERE WE WENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMPS A PULLOUT FROM
THE IRAN DEAL, ALTHOUGH
SUSPECTED BECAME A VIRTUAL
CERTAINTY WHEN THE PRIME
MINISTER PROOF THROUGH ISRAEL'S
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY THAT IRAN
HAVE BEEN LYING TO THE WORLD
WHEN IT WAS CONTINUING URANIUM
ENRICHMENT.
DOCUMENTS ARE PROOF POSITIVE
THAT IRAN LIED.
WHAT A SHOCK.
ON THE DAY OF THE WITHDRAWAL
FROM THE IRAN DEAL, BOMB
SHELTERS OPENED UP IN THE GOLAN
HEIGHTS.
THE ISRAELI ARMY WAS ON HIGH
ALERT IS ISRAEL BRACE FOR
IMMINENT ATTACKS.
AS WE PROCEEDED, THERE WERE NO
SIRENS, SCHOOL BUSES AND TAXIS
CONTINUE TO RUN.
BUT THAT NIGHT WE HAD THE
UNEQUIVOCAL SOUND OF ROCKETS AND
AT BREAKFAST WE FOUND OUT THAT
INDEED, THERE WAS A ROCKET
TOWARDS ISRAEL FROM INSIDE
SYRIA.
ISRAEL RESPONDED WITH STRATEGIC
PRECISIONS TARGETING MUNITIONS,
STORAGE WAREHOUSES, LOGISTICS,
AND INTEL SYSTEMS OF IRAN WITHIN
SYRIA.
ISRAEL DOES WHAT ISRAEL NEEDS TO
DO.
TODAY, IRANIANS ARE MARCHING
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES,
PROTESTING PRESIDENTS TRUMPS
DECISION TO WITHDRAW FROM THE
NUCLEAR DEAL.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD CONSIDER
PROTESTING $150 BILLION OBAMA
GAVE THEM IN CASH WAS NOT USED
TO BENEFIT THEM, BUT INSTEAD
USED TO SUPPORT NUCLEAR
DEVELOPMENT AND MILITARY BUDGET
WHICH HAS GROWN BY 40%.
NOW, OBAMA'S IRAN DEAL, MAKE NO
MISTAKE, DESTROYED 70 YEARS OF
BIPARTISAN U.S. FOREIGN POLICY.
HIS DELUSIONAL DO ABANDON ISRAEL
AND EGYPT, THE LARGEST ARAB
COUNTRY AND ALIENATED THE SUNNI
REGION, GUARANTEEING THAT THEY
WOULD FACE A NUCLEAR IRAN.
IRAN A LEADING STATE-SPONSORED
TERROR, EXPERTS DANGEROUS
MISSILES AND SUPPORTS TERRORIST
PROXIES A MALICIOUS LIKE HAS
BLOOD, AND THE TALIBAN.
THE IT
THE IDEA THAT IT HAS A
SUCCESSFUL NUCLEAR PROGRAM IS
ABSURD TO ANYONE WITH HALF A
BRAIN.
AS OBAMA TURNED HIS BACK ON THE
SLAUGHTER OF CHRISTIANS, HE
ALLOWED RUSSIA, THROUGH THIS
VACUUM TO BECOME A DOMINANT
REGIONAL PLAYER IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
DONALD TRUMP'S WITHDRAWAL WAS
THE UNITED STATES STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH OUR
ALLY, ISRAEL AGAINST THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
IT SENT A HUGE SIGNAL TO IRAN
AND SHIA MUSLIMS THAT WE STOOD
WITH MORE MODERATE SUNNIS.
AND THE WE JOINED EARLIER ABOUT
TAKING OUT WEAPONS, THEY CHOSE
TISH STAND AGAINST ISRAEL AND
THE UNITED STATES.
TRUMP HAS REASSURED THE WORLD
THAT HIS WORD IS WORTH MORE THAN
ANY FORMER U.S. PRESIDENTS LIKE
BILL CLINTON, GEORGE BUSH, AND
BARACK OBAMA, WHO ALL PROMISED
TO MOVE THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM
BUT DIDN'T DELIVER.
HIS WORD IS WORTH MORE THAN ANY
TREATY.
HE PROMISED, AND HE DELIVERED.
TRUMP NOT ONLY SENT A MESSAGE TO
IRAN, BUT RUSSIA AS WELL.
THE U.S. IS BACK AFTER THE OBAMA
YEARS.
HE RECOGNIZES THAT EVERYONE ELSE
IN THE WEST BLINDS THEMSELVES
TOO, THAT JERUSALEM IS THE ONE
AND ONLY CAPITAL OF ISRAEL.
BY TRUMP PUTTING THIS LIKE
HISTORY FOR THE LAST 3000 YEARS.
AND THAT IS JERUSALEM HAS BEEN
THE CAPITAL OF ONE PEOPLE'S
COUNTRY OR ONE KINGDOM.
THAT PEOPLE IS THE JEWS, AND
THAT COUNTRY IS AND WAS ISRAEL.
THE EMPIRES THAT TRIED TO
DESTROY ISRAEL ARE LONG GONE.
YET THEY STILL SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE AND PRACTICE THE SAME
RELIGION WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR JUDEO-CHRISTIAN RELIGION.
DONALD TRUMP SENT THEM A MESSAGE
TO REFLECT ON THEIR OWN HISTORY.
AND THAT IT WAS THE KING OF
PERSIA WHO THOUSAND YEARS BEFORE
MOHAMMED WAS BORN
MOHAMMED WAS BORN THAT SAID
JERUSALEM WAS THE CAPITAL OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE'S COUNTRY.
THERE WILL BE NO SHIA NATIONS
THAT WILL DESTROY JERUSALEM ANY
LONGER.
DONALD TRUMP RECOGNIZE HISTORY.
HE, LIKE KING CYRUS BEFORE HIM
TO FULFILL THE BIBLICAL PROCESS
OF THE GODS WORSHIPED BY JEWS,